a shocking video is causing outrage in
Columbus Ohio it shows a 20 year old man
his name is Donovan Lewis being shot by
police while lying in his bed now the
footage shows he appears to have
something in his hand which police have
later suggested may have been a vape pen
a warning you may find these images
disturbing Tino Ramos is with our
Columbus affiliate that's wbns has more
on the story
Donovan if you don't come to the door
I'm going to kick it in
after minutes of knocking the Columbus
canine unit took two men into custody
officers and their police dog then
searched the apartment for the man they
came to arrest Donovan Lewis was accused
of punching and shoving his pregnant
girlfriend and had multiple outstanding
warrants including a felony for improper
handling of a firearm the dog then
alerted police Donovan was in a back
bedroom that dog's gonna bite you if you
don't come out moments after opening the
bedroom door a flashlight Shines on
Lewis who is lying on a bed officer
Ricky Anderson a 30-year veteran on the
force then fires a single shot striking
Lewis before holstering his gun officers
yell at Lewis to crawl out of the room
when he doesn't they enter the bedroom
and handcuff the suspect stop resisting
he's pulling away Pat him down pat him
down make sure he's good all right let's
get him out to the medic you're all
right buddy you're all right we're
coming out coming out at least three
officers then carry Lewis out by his
arms and legs and eventually really
place them on the ground of the
apartment complex
Donovan you got another night
one of the officers begins to perform
CPR until an ambulance arrives and takes
Lewis to the hospital where he died less
than an hour later Columbus's police
chief says Lewis appeared to be holding
a vape pen and no weapon was found the
head of the Columbus Urban League calls
the video disturbing and heartbreaking
but is calling for calm we're all in a
position now where
um it's not about being angry but it's
it's about how do we stack hands and
find Solutions
now we can tell you the police chief
says the Ohio Bureau of Criminal
investigations will look into this
incident she also says she's committed
into holding those police officers
responsible if there's any wrongdoing
now we're expected to hear from the
Lewis family today a news conference is
scheduled for later this morning back to
you
and we'll learn more there Tina Ramos
thank you very much